welcome to the man of Recaps this is the
dragon Prince seasons one through three
welcome to the magical land of zadia
where everything's connected to one of
the magic Primal sources everything that
is except for humans feeling left out
humans invented their own type of magic
dark magic which sacrifices magical
creatures to draw on their Primal energy
the elves were not cool with this so
banished Humanity to the other side of
the continent and had guarding the
border the Dragon King but just recently
somehow Humanity killed the Dragon King
as well as his only egg the dragon
Prince so our Story begins in the happy
human Kingdom of katalis with Prince
Callum a funny nerdy guy technically
he's the stepper Prince from before his
mom married the king and tragically she
died but otherwise it's a happy family
with the good King hero and his
half-brother Prince ezrin who's a
good-hearted little rascal with his
animal companion bait the frog dog but
now trouble arrives with a group of
Moonshadow elf assassins here to kill
the king and the princes as revenge for
the Dragon King it's the first
assassination mission for the newest
member Rayla and so eager to prove
herself she sneaks into the castle alone
like time to die you filthy humans but
they they discovered the dragon egg was
not destroyed if they can get it back to
its mother in zadia it could be the
start of making peace unfortunately the
other elves don't want peace they want
revenge and so Rayla and our human
princes run off on their own while
tragically the Moonshadow elves carry
out their mission and do kill the king
the Boise kelp from their aunt Amaya a
badass General but she's been fighting
elves all her life she's not ready to
hear that this is a good one so the
princess pretend Rayle is holding them
hostage and this group is on their own
so our group's off on a whirlwind
adventure and they have a lot of fun
times together like raila doing her best
human impression and long story short
they become best friends back in katalis
Lord viren is the High Mage and he's a
complicated character because he really
was King Hero's good friend and just
wants to do what's best for Humanity but
he loves dark magic and is kind of a
villain because it's like oh no if the
king and princes are dead I guess I have
to be king but he's interrupted when
Amaya comes back with the news that the
princes are still alive she has her
friend Glenn stay behind to keep an eye
on viren but he's immediately imprisoned
and he spends seasons one through three
in the dungeon soviron sends his own
children to go find the princes his son
is Soren an endearingly dumb jock but
he's a good guy who's friends with the
princes so when his dad's like Soren
when you find them I need you to kill
them he's like wait what his sister
Claudia is an adorably quirky skilled
Mage and incidentally callum's Crush she
would not be okay with killing the
princes so her dad doesn't tell her that
part just says the dragon egg is the
most important thing now remember humans
can only do dark magic but Claudia has
an incredibly rare Primal stone that
lets her connect to the sky Arcana on
his way out Callum snatched it and very
quickly learned how to use it wow you're
a wizard Harry during their Adventure he
learns to master it and it becomes
really important to him but now they
have a huge problem when the dragon egg
falls in some frozen water oh no they
need a magic veterinarian luckily they
hear of one who lives up on the cursed
Caldera but the way is blocked by a
giant spider but Prince ezrin for some
reason can talk to animals and he's like
yo this spider ain't talking cause it's
an illusion yes it's a friendly
Moonshadow elf who's living up here but
because it's all Illusions she can't
heal the egg the only way to heal it is
to hatch it and a storm dragon can only
hatch during a storm luckily callum's
carrying a storm around in his pocket to
goodbye Primal Stone blam oh big storm
and then oh what's this the dragon egg
hatches and it's the absolute cutest
little baby dragon you could possibly
imagine imagine so in season two Zim is
the group's new cutest animal companion
sorry bait but I mean come on but now
Soren and Claudia catch up to our crew
and Callum explains we're not kidnapped
we're friends on an adventure so viren's
kids face a crisis of conscience help
their friends or listen to their dad in
the end they trust that their dad knows
best so they try to capture the princes
but oh it was an illusion yeah Rayla saw
that one coming so our crew flies out of
there Calum now very disappointed in his
former crush and so the journey to zadia
continues with a lot of fun Shenanigans
like this double eyepatch pirate with a
seeing eye parrot there's a lot of funny
one-off characters on the show back in
katalis Lord viren is very anti-zadia he
thinks the only way Humanity will ever
really be free is if they are wiped out
he calls a meeting with the other human
kingdoms and gives them his PowerPoint
on the dangers of zadia the only way to
stop him is an all-out War the other
kingdoms are mostly in except for the
young Queen Anya who's like yo man if we
keep retaliating this war will never end
we should be making peace for example
Soren and Claudia come to our border
village where a dragon is just keep and
watch it hasn't attacked yet but Soren's
like well I'm gonna attack first
unfortunately he misses and escalates
the situation it's up to Claudia to do
some dark magic and oh it's this thing
the princes and raila are nearby and
they fight to rescue this Dragon but all
season long without his Primal Stone
Callum is feeling useless but Callum has
a crazy theory that if he can remember
what the sky or Cannon felt like he can
forge a connection to it eventually
though he had amidst defeat he has to
accept that magical creatures are born
with their connection and humans just
are not so now he helps with the only
type of magic humans can do dark magic
oh Callum don't do it but though he does
and uses it for good to free this Dragon
but this gives him an awful dark magic
hangover and he's out of commission for
a bit and he has a dream Vision Quest
facing off against his dark magic self
yes join me on the dark side but he
tries to explain that dark magic isn't
inherently evil and that's a big
question I mean is it for example some
years back there was a terrible famine
but viren knew a spell that could fix it
so the adults crossed the border into
zadia to get the ingredient the heart of
a magma Titan and it worked guitarless
was saved incidentally the boy's mother
Queen Sarai came along on this adventure
but the Dragon King wasn't happy they
crossed the border and oh he killed her
that's where she died now Claudia is
also faced with the dark magic dilemma
because when the drag escaped it
retaliated against Soren and instantly
broke every bone in his body and she
figures morally sacrificing this magic
baby deer is no worse than say eating
lamb chops so she goes with it bust out
a big dark magic spell and heals her
brother but dark magic does take a toll
on the user too and now she's got this
cool white streak in her hair so Callum
is almost convinced he can use dark
magic for good until he realizes no wait
obviously it's super evil so he banishes
xender demons and now when he wakes up
he's like I understand the sky Arcanum
Callum come on it's just not physically
possible for a human to do Primal magic
but wait what's this oh he does it first
human ever there's more to it than we
understand now this cool guy Corbett
shows up with bad news about the king
finally tells ezrin his father's dead
Ezra figures he's got a bail on this
adventure it's his duty to go back to
catalus and Rule as king and indeed
guitarless needs him because Lord virin
is up to no good he has the strange
mirror he took from the dragon King's
Lair and he finally figures out how to
turn it on and there's a room in there
with a person it's a cool looking star
elf who guides vir in through a Magic
Ritual to what's this oh a caterpillar
teleported over there and it runs on
Bluetooth now he can talk to him and
this guy has an unreasonably deep and
sexy voice his name is aravos and when
Baron tries to look him up he's been
magically scrubbed from history which
you know should be a red flag but he's
real persuasive like hey man I can help
you and he teaches viren some ancient
magic to create fake elf assassins he
sends him off to attack the other
kingdoms now they'll have to join the
war and with arabos's help he goes full
beast mode to take over catalus
officially right now but it's like yo
man chill you're getting ahead of
yourself surrender for now trust me and
so in season three Rayla Callum and Zim
have finally made it into Xavier the
board is no longer guarded by The Dragon
King but a new Dragon has taken his
place Soul rhaegum he's a real old guy
who was there when humans first invented
dark magic and he was of the mind they
should exterminate him immediately so
this guy had to fight back and oh still
stardom and so even with an elf and the
dragon Prince he still smells human and
things get heated but with some quick
thinking Rayland Callum managed to trap
him there and get away so zadia is truly
a beautiful place where everything's
magical and Rayla and Callum have a lot
of fun together as they approach rayless
Village Callum puts on his best
self-disguise but they have bigger
problems because when they get there no
one can see them raila has been ghosted
yes they assume she deserted her
assassin duties so this magical Exile is
the punishment and here as reyless
feeling bad about her Village Callum
Comforts her like you're an amazing
person Rayla and oh it's happening the
reylum ship is set in sail they need to
cool skywang elf named NYX who gives him
a ride across the desert on her giant
camel to the Oasis guarded by the
Wonderwall she tries to steals him but
Zim bites her wing and she ends up in a
bit of trouble when Rayla busts in to
save her and so they end up as kind of
friends back in katalis King Ezra is
adjusting to the crown there's some
perks like infinite jelly Tarts but
there's also hard decisions to be made
viren's fake elf assassins did their job
so now the other human kingdoms are
ready to go to war but young king Ezra
is a wise little dude we're not
retaliating we're trying to make peace
unfortunately the other human kingdoms
if you're not with us you're against us
we declare war on you faced with
fighting a war to try to avoid war Ezra
makes a difficult decision to abdicate
in favor of Lord viren yes viren was in
the dungeons rethinking his life choice
is about taking advice from an evil
caterpillar but arabos is like come on
man stick with me in fact he cocoons up
his eye so now he can see him as well as
hear him and now his master plans worked
viren is officially legally King the
whole point of Ezra's deal is that any
soldiers who don't want a war zadia are
allowed to sit this one out no
repercussions but most of the Army's
still sticking around so viren finally
gets his war on zadia but now fully
turning against his dad is Soren he
really is not the brightest but he's
smart enough to figure out that his dad
telling him to murder the princes is you
know bad but his sister Claudia is not
ready to hear it she's like sorry and
you must have misunderstood him she
really looks up to her dad and is still
totally buying his talk about how this
is what's best for Humanity so Soren
enacts his genius plan to sneak Ezra out
of the castle they meet up with some
other good guys and get him a ride to
zadia Callum and raila have finally
reached the home of the Dragon Queen the
storm Spire but right outside is a giant
dragon statue that's no statue that is
the petrified dragon king yeah we see
how viren had the dark magic spell and
King hero who's normally a good guy but
was blinded by Rage with revenge for his
wife went through with a 10-0 that's how
they killed him but now ezron flies in
our gang's reunited and they finally
completed their Quest brought the dragon
Prince Zim back to his mom but there's
bad news with her husband dancing
unthought to be dead the dragon Queen
fell into a depression coma and there's
more bad news because viren's coming
he's getting advice from his new
invisible friend arabos and his children
think it's a little weird he's talking
to his little bug pal but arabos has had
a long time to think about how to
conquer zadia he's like first stop the
sun elves he rolls up alone to ask for
safe passage but they're like well
obviously not we're going to execute you
meanwhile Antonia was stationed on the
border and was skirmishing against on
elves including this one who's her match
but one day Amaya saves her life which
is a nice thing to do but now she's
captured during her imprisonment these
two became friends and now when she
explains what viren's doing it's like oh
no it must be a trap and indeed it is
because as they try to execute him oh
what's this he bars out a huge
caterpillar before anyone can react he
corrupts the sun staff and possesses
this guy yeah aravos is back he
instantly kills the sun elf queen but he
can't hold this for him he still needs
Baron for now so now viren looking very
suspiciously evil is like what's up Army
I can make you all immune to fire he
fails to mention the side effect though
it turns you into a lava monster most of
the Army is not cool with this but it's
not a democracy he's not asking now he's
leading an army of fire monsters Soren
has still been hanging around but takes
this as his cue to fully bail he has his
final combo with his sister Claudia like
come on claude's Dad's obviously evil
but she's not ready to hear it so
siblings divided he makes it in time to
warn our crew and they're like well to
keep them safe I guess we better bail
but raila won't run she wants to stand
and fight because her parents were
Dragon guards and shame themselves by
running when the Dragon King was killed
but Callum does some magic to see what
really happened that night and her
parents didn't run they fought to the
last but their bodies were never found
because it seems like beer and added
them to his collection yes he sucks out
elf souls and puts them in a coin watch
out for that now antimai arrives with
her new elf girlfriend and an army of
sun elves so it's time to prepare for
the final battle yes epic battle time
our cruise outnumbered but they got some
great Fighters including Callum busting
out magic but the other side of course
has magic too wow boom but one really
strong Ally for teams Adia is of course
the dragons yeah Boston in breathing
fire Game of Thrones style unfortunately
this is exactly why arabos wanted to
make the Army immune to fire so they
nullify the dragon advantage and so the
situation seems dire but wait who's this
it's Queen Anya coming in leading an
army of all the good humans ready to
fight for peace all the good minor
characters joined The Fray hilariously
including the Royal pastry chef
soviron's Army is defeated and the day
is saved except for viren himself oh no
he's got desrin Starin has to bust in
there don't you do it dad and how he
stabs his father his sister Claudia is
wildly disappointed in him but not too
sad because this was just a distraction
yes the real veer-in has snuck up the
mountain coming from baby Zoom he's
trying to suck him up into a Vortex
absorb his powers I guess for some big
boost Dragon God Rael is here to protect
him but oh they knock her swords away
and so she's left with no choice but to
tackle veeren off the mountain callum's
not gonna let that happen instantly eats
himself down to rescue her and he does
have a plan because earlier he learned a
spell to get magewings and luckily he
remembers it cause boom callum's flying
saves his girlfriend these two are in
love and veeran fall to his death so now
the day is truly saved and more good
news the dragon Queen wakes up oh mother
and son reunited she sees this Alliance
of humans and elves working together to
strive for peace and it looks like it is
a happy ending for the dragon Prince but
we're not done yet this story is just
getting started Baron wakes up like wow
I fell a long way it's a miracle I
survived but his daughter Claudia with a
lot more white hair is like well
technically you didn't but I brought you
back dad and your little bug pal well
he's not so little anymore he's
cocooning who is this erebos and what
more trouble is he gonna cause find out
on season 4 of the Dragon Prince
if you liked this recap hit that
subscribe button for more of the best
Recaps of TV and movies
[Music]